hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up today
the National Grid spent over 200 million
pounds last year switching off wind
turbines on the windiest days that's as
the energy regulator tells Sky News the
grid is not yet fit for purpose
the UK would have to devote half of all
its Farmland to Growing biofuels if
Britain is to meet its plans for zero
emission flying
and new pictures of the first bison calf
born wild in Britain for centuries as
she turns six months old
foreign
[Music]
to the Daily climate show where we track
the changes to our world and investigate
some of the potential solutions to The
Climate crisis now the National Grid is
spending hundreds of millions of pounds
a year paying wind generators to switch
off their turbines on the windiest days
that's because Britain's electricity
infrastructure isn't built for the
amount of renewable electricity that it
is now required to carry our climate and
energy correspondent Hannah Thomas Peter
has been reporting on this story today
she's here in the studio with us hello
Hannah so what is going on here this is
one of those stories that really
illustrates how difficult it is to
decarbonize power generation which we
must according to a government pledge by
2035 and ensure continued smooth
security of supply and the fundamental
problem we've got is this we generate a
lot of electricity using wind power in
the north of the country in Scotland and
in the North Sea but a lot of the demand
comes from the densely populated areas
in the South to keep the lights on the
National Grid has got to move that
electricity from the north to the South
and the issue is that we don't actually
have enough cables to do that we've got
a real bottleneck in terms of
transmission between England and
Scotland so on the windiest days there's
actually too much for those cables to
handle without risking damage so the
National Grid electricity system
operator has no choice but to call the
turbines or to instruct the wind turbine
generators to turn off their wind
turbines they pay for that around 200
million pounds last year and then of
course we have to turn on gas powered
stations closer to the location of the
demand perhaps near a London and that
according to one calculation using
publicly available data was around 700
million pounds last year now Renewables
UK which is the trade body for Renewable
Power Generation has said that they've
been calling for grid upgrades for years
and they are so worried about this issue
that they think it could actually
jeopardize our Net Zero targets
I would say it's a really huge risk um I
think you know first of all because we
we have to pay these costs we're wasting
power instead of exporting it or using
it and this is really cheap power that
we're wasting um and I would also say as
an investment signal it's it's not great
um if you think about a developer that
wants to build wind farms in the UK they
know that it's not easy to connect to
the transmission system they know
there's not enough capacity uh so it's a
really huge non-financial barrier that
we're seeing again it's a big deterrent
hmm okay Hannah so what can they do
about this well I mean the first thing
to say is this isn't a problem just
restricted to wind uh you know the
National Grid pays other power
generators to ramp Supply up and down
depending on what's needed but there's
such a focus on wind because it's such a
critical part of our Energy Mix both now
and into the future and the National
Grid the energy regulator off germ and
the government all know that this
particular issue this transmission issue
is a real problem there is a big plan to
upgrade the grid cost of tens of
billions of pounds but also we're going
to need a lot more storage in the form
of batteries potentially even green
hydrogen all coming online much faster
by 2030 because right now the energy
regulator off germ has admitted to Sky
News that the grid is not yet fit for
purpose as we transition to this clean
green future
okay Hannah thank you
right well let's have a look at some of
the day's other news now and the
government has announced that that three
Marine habitats will receive the highest
level of protection by July this year
alambi Bay in the Irish sea dolphin
heads in the Eastern Channel and
Northeast of farness deep will become
the first three highly protected Marine
areas in English Waters they'll be
protected in an effort to reverse the
impact of human activity on marine
ecosystems like construction and
dredging
everyday items like bananas coffee and
chocolate could soon become harder to
get your hands on due to climate change
that's according to a new report from
the fair trade Foundation researchers
found some of the UK's favorite foods
are becoming endangered because they
originate from countries that are
vulnerable to threats caused by climate
change deforestation and biodiversity
loss loss
The National Trust will use a stone age
Woodland management technique in a bid
to boost Nightingale numbers in Suffolk
copacing involves the cutting of trees
close to the ground on a regular cycle
it encourages fast New Growth which then
boosts flowers and brambles creating
nesting habitats for Nightingales whose
population has declined 90 percent in
the last 50 years the process will be
used at Sutton who a woodland that was
mostly felt in 1987.
now for all the talk about sustainable
aviation fuel and Jet zero you'd be
forgiven for thinking the possibility of
a mission free flying wasn't too far
around the corner well apparently not
according to a new scientific report
which says there is no clear path to
sustainable Aviation at current levels
of demand Professor Marcel McManus is
the director of The Institute for
sustainability at the University of bath
and a working group member from the
Royal Society which is the group behind
this research
we looked at four main different types
of alternative fuels military biofuels
we looked at hydrogen ammonia and what
we're calling e-fuels
um and what we could what we've
concluded is that there's no real silver
bullet
um so there's no real one alternative
um for replacing fossil-based kerosene
each one of these fuels has advantages
but they also have disadvantages in the
short term what we need is something
like a biofuel we've looked at a
numerous biofuels ones which are made
from Woody crops and these can be quite
beneficial compared with fossil fuels
but a lot of the biofuels don't
necessarily meet the renewable energy
directive sustainable aviation fuel
targets so we need to be focusing on
those that do so those are things like
the sewage or the algae and the
municipal Solid Waste but we can't
really do that at scale yet so we still
need to put some Research into that area
in the longer term I think some of the
Alternatives with hydrogen and ammonia
and particularly some of these e-fuels
that's really interesting because if we
can capture carbon dioxide from flue gas
or even in the future and directly from
the air and turn these into fuels then
we have an added benefit of dealing with
carbon dioxide one of the benefits of
some of these
um fuels such as the e-fuels or the
hydrogen or the ammonia is that they use
renewable electricity to produce them
and as we go more towards having
renewable electricity as we're sort of
with the energy transition we're going
to have periods of time where we have
excess solar or XX wind if we can use
that to then produce a storable fuel
then that's beneficial both for our
electricity Supply but also for our fuel
demand I think the most important
message is that really we need to invest
in a series of these different fuels and
we're not going to have one solution
that fits all in order to help us meet
Net Zero
just a reminder that you can catch the
climate Show with Tom Heat this weekend
he's going to be in Scotland learning
all about the importance of peat and how
traditional Industries like whiskey are
facing up to the damage caused by
digging it up that's on Saturday and
Sunday at 3 30 here on Sky News
and if you have a question about Pete or
how it's used that you'd like Tom to try
and get answered on the program scan
this QR code on your screen right now
and if you scan this QR code you can
listen to this week's edition of climate
cast you can listen And subscribe now
wherever you get your podcast from
just before we go have a look at this
a bison Ranger has taken photos of the
UK's first free roaming bison calf as
she approaches
six months in age she was born in early
September and was a welcome surprise to
the Wilder bleen project which is a
rewilding initiative in Woodland near
Canterbury in Kent they're released
they've released the free Roman bison to
shape the landscape and help make it
more resilient to climate change while
also fighting the biodiversity crisis
she's cute isn't she thank you so much
for watching that's all from us today
join us again on the daily climate show
same time same place tomorrow
foreign